Hôm nay, Hôm nay tăng thân mời thưởng Việt Mỹ một lần nửa thấp bài.
Chúng Việt thông qua dự lợp nân sách cảm thời,
gió đàn cộng hoa hậu thống, nhằm chấm rất tình trạng đóng cử chính phụ cáo xài.
Cô bà viêu thức người ba về dự lợp này, chỉ đặt 50 mươi phía thuận,
thiếu sấu phía uống sau với mất tối thiếu cần thiết.
Để được thung qua, việc mấy tăng hình sách đã khiến nhiều cơ qua li bang hường hoạt động.
Chúng khi hàng trưởng người Mỹ phải đối mặt với người cơ mất mồn hỗ trợ lương thực.
Cũng ngày, lý mình gồm, hàng năm băng và đặc khu của luôn biê,
đã an đệ đơn kiện chính quyền tổng tổng mấy đương năng trăm,
bây kế hoạt các giảm chậu cấp truyền chính hỗ trợ dình giấm bộ sông sát,
bố nỗ trợ cho khoảng 1,5 trụ người.
Trúc khi đó, một thường phá liên băng đã ra phán quyết,
năm chính phổ xa khảnh nhân viên trong thời gian tổng gửa,
khi chẳng chấp pháp li vẫn còn tịp sĩnh.